I don't care what you are you're fat
it's in Your Heart Right Sam be proud
Brothers we kiss we hug
uh any black on my lips
I make jokes about the black people and
why not because I'm that one
remember the words of a great negro I
say that honestly all peoples are alike
we are all working you live in my
neighborhood I live in yours right Sam
right are you crazy
[Music]
Chinese Japanese
Filipino Mayes you're a jab
three years in the jungle looking for
your uncle
God bless you my friend what is your
first name
Joe Joe my ass Joe during World War II
they were all Joe you're a Jew you gotta
be with that noise if you're not you're
an eagle
nice to see are you Japanese Chinese
are you Chinese
we Jews we love you especially on Sunday
knock it off knock it off why I can talk
China very pretty girls you can't talk
to the Chinese like that way all the
money foreign
[Music]
keeps calling me on the phone saying why
is that black guy get them bigger lines
when you go to bed tonight
try to listen for a clock
your part George is getting smaller and
smaller tell him what you told me how
you fed up with the blacks and you don't
want them in your neighborhood
[Applause]
but we lead the blacks without them to
be no Olympics
about New York Italians Jews Irish
whatever the hell you are your people
that's what I love about this city
there's a chemistry I swear to god
you're an eye are you an Irishman you an
Irish kid
what are you a bird
no you're a Catholic and I'm a Jew and
Sammy you're black I'm sorry
and I love the black people we need you
people I swear because no Jew is going
to make up a train
right Chinese this girl here if you're
not get your eyes fixed
I'm a Chinese box and they're
going who's Chinese who's Chinese I kid
the black man and you know that baby and
you were beautiful to Telly Telly is a
great Greek and you're a great black man
and I'm a Jew and I say this for my
heart on behalf of the Greeks and the
Jewish people don't move into the
neighborhood
if you ain't black you fell into a
bucket of M M's
[Music]
Battalion who's Italian
[Applause]
they could have used you
remember the Italians said in World War
II run
[Applause]
anyway
God bless you black or white we're
working for a same cause to find your
work anyway I've been doing so great
with me God bless you trust is a Jew and
Safari anyway uh
anyway
I'll bring love and I bring peace
and I've been kindness and warm
I love the black people
the black people in my life
my world
they do what they're told
we're honoring Mr T
why
I met this man many many years ago on
the 7-Eleven store and he said give me
your money
you're going to look at it Filipinos
are you Filipinos oh God two and a half
years two and a half years looking for
your uncle
Navy World War II big one big one
Cebu taclobin the guy in golf Linda Nowa
I was there all all I'll be with you in
a minute
all trees all jungle now big cities
wonderful we went up to Manila and
MacArthur's still sitting there going am
I dead
God bless you great country I'm not
going back there
would you rise sir would you rise
Japanese Chinese sure since the water
all Chinese
[Applause]
see they're laughing and one of their
guys is up in my room now taking my
jewelry anyway
be funny
first black kid I ever saw it'll
definitely never play basketball
how anyway yeah
it's four Mexicans in the back fighting
to get in and we got one black lady
sitting in the front going I'll get a
frog
right now
there's another black guy
well they're both with white chicks well
that's great
that's that's nice that's nice what's
your first name brother what's first
name
Keenan sure anyway you mean a black guy
yet named Keenan it's usually Willy or
Muhammad I'll tell you I'm only kidding
can I see you on the 7-Eleven store
anyway uh
was five of us up against the counter
is he laughing take a look
you see teeth coming towards me go for
the elephant gun
anyway
I make fun of the black so why not
because I'm that one that's how it is
would you would you stand up there
[Applause]
can I grab your bottle legs I want to
dust
the Chinese Chinese no the maybe I'm not
you it's a real Jew with the nose if
you're not a Jew or you're a parakeet
down in a cage look at the knot as
you're breathing my socks are coming up
I'll tell you are you are you you're not
Chinese no that lady there no she needs
her eyes fixed I'll tell you this though
sit right in the front door literally
where are we I should make fun of the
Chinese because the Jews need them on
Sunday so we have a place to eat I tell
you
separated yeah you're black I'll tell
you this though